the following is a conversation with yay
the legendary artist producer and
designer formerly known as Kanye West on
this The Lex Friedman podcast
based off of our connection and just you
being a friend I need to show you
my two tech companies and get your
perspective on it
because now I have friends that can give
a perspective like when I would work on
albums I had other friends that worked
on albums and they would give me their
perspectives on it you wanna do this
we are doing it this is part of it this
is part of it absolutely all right
beautiful oh what I wanted to finish the
thing is okay you're going to ask me
different questions but I'm about
growing and building and bringing the
idea to life so when I see you I say oh
this guy understands how to hire
Engineers where I'm coming from coming
from Hollywood coming from press coming
from media all of the guys you know that
so many of the guys that have been like
voices and faces and Talking Heads
whatever have not understood how to
engineer product and that's the reason
why I was able to jump past everyone in
the entertainment field and become
um you know whatever the net worth is 11
billion imma stop putting the whole
black thing on my worth like let's just
see where I am on the scale of life
because that's a cop-out for me to say
Rich's black guy of all time because
that's feeding into the same you know
trauma economy that black lives matter
feeds into that's why I love and respect
Engineers that's the only thing that we
really need to teach in school is
engineering we don't need to teach
history we don't need to teach anything
that is subjective it needs to only be
engineering taught in school and
everything else needs to be recessed
nothing that at all any Force subjective
information is just to weaken and
indoctrinate
our species and that's what schools do
now as an engineer I love hearing you
say that but to push back history is not
the interpretation of History might be
subjective but history has some facts
and they're useful to give a grounding
to the way you do engineering I don't
100 believe in anything any concept of
the future or any concept of History
because history was just written by The
Victors yeah so if I see stuff happen on
the day that later that day is reported
wrong so how wrong is something reported
a thousand years ago and why would we
argue about something that's not in the
now because that's the only thing that
everyone can agree upon is that it is
now right now yo you try not to make the
mistakes of the past that's the
usefulness of History The Limited
usefulness the biggest mistake from the
past that we keep making is looking at
the past too much giving too much value
to the past too much value to the past
we are now we are now we are here we are
one species We Are One race
we're here
and
it's time and the leadership is changing
because you have Elon as a leader yea as
a leader and we are the top leaders
we're more influential than the
presidents
so you're a human being
with engineering challenges before you
with a stun player with parlor
what's the hardest thing in front of you
on the engineering front that's the
first sentence that any of our species
needs to hear when they're born
You Are a Human Being when engineering
challenges and I consider consider
challenges to be opportunities in front
of you yeah literally like let me see a
piece I need to write that down that's
the beginning of our new species
Constitution
I'm gonna do the paper like this why put
in widescreen this this for Ridley
um uh you
are
no let me like you
are
a
being
with
in
J Nearing
[Music]
opportunities
or challenges opportunities
I'm sorry I don't spell as good as John
Legend
opportunities
and
be for you
I like the before because it can mean as
you can mean forward or before you this
right here I've always said I'm the top
five writer and human existence but at
this like this right here is pushing me
to like number four number three
it's a good one because who would you
say is the top and it's top right in
human resistant we know who it is that's
subjective who's that it's factual
though it's like okay who's the top
person in Tech History
it's not subjective
wow there's a non-subjective answer
to both of those both of those people
have influence 30 percent
of our existence so the influences is
the main metric of greatness okay one
person yeah 30 of our language was the
English language was written by them the
other person 30 of the products we use
was led by them
Steve Jobs yeah
he puts Steve above like elons of the
world because Steve is a designer not
he's a designer engineer but he's a
design he's a Visionary in the design
space well I would link to him because
I'm not an engineer right so I'm more
like then you're an engineer if if Steve
is an engineer you're an engineer
essentially he's a cultural engineer
like the people who run the emotions of
the world and Run the World off of
people's emotions right now are uh
social engineers and social engineering
is so important like like
um City design there's a fancier word
for that
um but I was uh I was in Ochsner last
night to see Anthony jeselnick and I
gotta find out what his opening joke was
because I'm doing interviews and I'm
thinking I'm funny
and I like that he said he just kept on
saying 20 year anniversary I've been
doing this for 20 years and his opening
joke
was so high level I realized that I
wasn't funny I realized that this dude
is a professional at what he does and so
many things are subjective I always talk
about this it's like you know people are
arguing like it's Emily Ratajkowski the
hottest you know person and I'm like
that's such a subjective thing but like
if you go and shoot three pointers with
Steph Curry it's not subjective right or
if you go and compare bank accounts for
Elon it's not subjective and another
thing that's not subjective
porn
what about it dick size it's not
subjective you could measure
[Laughter]
but porn is more about uh more than just
dick size and greatness is more than the
size of the bank account right so
there's a simple greatness is subjective
though right so you do do you care about
the stuff
that's objective or subjective more
because greatness to me is what matters
the bank account comes and goes
the impact on our society like you said
social engineering the impact on the
collective intelligence of our species
that what permeates throughout the rest
of the time I like what you said the
impact
I'm taking notes
how did you would you say the impact
collective intelligence of our species
the impact on the
Collective
and
damn
is writing down the words that came out
of my dumb mouth I have made it in life
there's a lot of people that have kind
of like sit through sat through I wanted
to wear a different color hoodie because
I was just tired of seeing this hoodie
and all the interviews and
there's a lot of kids
that are with me they see what I'm
saying yeah and they had to sit through
all of the muck of all the previous
interviews to get to this
every interview
has been
just
an emotional
it's just like been an argument up to
this point this is the first
of
this is the next Frontier of where our
our species is gonna head it starts here
it starts with you Lex
so this is the first time I heard you
say the word engineering at least so
many times which I love hearing so this
is where you're at you're like that
newborn you're a being with engineering
opportunities yeah and we're all a
newborn because then Christianity say
born again we're all newborns and
everyone can uh everyone shout out like
the word Ken uh
shell the only thing about shell is like
it kind of dictates and can kind of kind
of lets people off the hook so I haven't
found the perfect post Shakespeare and
post Steve Jobs and post Elon and post
yay and post Drake way to communicate
this
um
but we update and we do and what the
current media structure no it's not
actually nothing that's holding us
there's nothing actually holding us back
because I'm still alive
I'm still alive like they could have
killed me at you know George Bush don't
care about black people they could have
killed me at Beyonce had the best video
but we're here now so we just keep on
leaning and leaning and leaning and
there's these things where I just think
about you know there'll be times when
I'm at War
and
every now and then when the when the
bombs stop going off and all the
headlines and the smearing and all that
stuff going off I think about my family
and I think about Kim
and I'll think about how you know King
Koopa has her in the castle right now
and just on uh Mario Brothers you know
how it is just go for the princess and
you get to this level and it's like
I just sung the song wrong right and
then they take the princess again
which one are you Mario yeah
what's your uh favorite thing the thing
you love the most about Kim
from a Mario perspective and the
princess
looking back
was there a moment she's definitely my
favorite of all time yeah was there a
moment that you know like that catches
you off guard and you say I love this
human being
yeah I mean
it's just the the DNA is like she's a
mix of Rob and Chris
can you explain
I mean that's like
a really high pool right there
those are like two geniuses
so okay so like the entire history of uh
evolution of the human species created
this DNA that created this being there's
a life there there's a set of memories
in the history that brought you together
and you're like damn I like this DNA
yeah and so certain people have just
like hi DNA Ivanka Trump has high DNA
you know it's like how's your DNA
pretty good uh I I think we've seen that
it's been proven I mean but look at my
look at my mom and look at my dad you
know me and my dad have a water
purification Center in the Dr
uh right now and my dad is the original
Steve Jobs and he was blocked by people
around him and people were using him and
taking advantage and you know not
believing in his vision he's my dad's
the educated version of yay
what'd you learn about life from your
dad
and my dad got girls too but those are
the small details that's a big detail
being that I found my dad's you know
Playboy when I was five years old it it
greatly affected my motivation
yeah all right so that's part of the
engine that drives yay absolutely I
remember when Pharrell was first in all
the videos
and my girl was like uh girls like
Pharrell and I was like I want girls to
like me too funny that that's behind all
the ambition all the drive that's how we
make people
that's how people are made
it's the desire to be loved
is that
at the individual level just being
noticed and also at the societal level
at scale well now
I've I've gone past I'm like at that
place
where Nikolai Tesla was uh
uh later into his career where it wasn't
about being loved it wasn't about
sitting at the dinner parties next to
Anna Wintour and stuff it was about
getting the idea across
so I have these
cells
that are very
and I just keep on saying really Scott
but really Scott has a special
anointing it isn't just sci-fi what he's
doing
there's something in there just like
George Lucas
there's something different that's there
so
what are you drawing I'm drawing these
new living cells that we will exist in
and this is over
okay let's do like
I don't like talking about money because
like man make money up anyways like four
quadrillion
respected dollars and then you have
other forms of currency of course social
currency is super important right now
but this is a drawing
and it's at a pretty good place
now this will be forty thousand square
feet I want to start just talking to
meters I just think we should go to
anything to restore the Tower of Basil
like they said when the uh
I'll just draw a person here for scale
uh yeah that would help
okay
what do you think of that look at my
person see the scale in this room
all right so
wait the dot is the person yeah
I'm saying it's 40 000 square feet
but that would be like what are the
other parts of the cell
okay so what it's a screen it doesn't go
all the all the way to the top and it's
one hole for light but the water and the
light and air all come in from the top
so that's like
like the mouth and then this is the
belly button we're God's iPhone where
his greatest creation
so this is all connected these are all
connected yes I'm drawing how these
other cells go next to each other what's
the vision here
happiness do we talk about like what's
the motivation like yeah there's a
motivation somewhere in the back of my
mind
of
my family
and
if it's like where Moses Smite The Rock
and God didn't allow him
to
get to the promised land because the
promised land is family that is the
problem that is
Earth I mean that is heaven on Earth is
family family is heaven that's the
promised land and for your family to be
together
uh so say I smite The Rock and God
doesn't let me
have my family back my mission and life
is still to
promote families
at all costs and make families existence
easier so you take this thing you put
localize
a localized Farm see if it's in
community that we we do localized
growing and then we partner with big
Pharma and all and say hey you're
actually going to make more money
by making better food
because at the end of the day you want
money right now it's like everyone knows
that between the pesticides and between
the medical industry and especially
America that we're keeping people sick
and we know that McDonald's makes food
that kills people and you know Coca-Cola
selling you know sugar water and all
this like
just in case I haven't pissed off enough
people in power yeah okay so you're
gonna piss off the shirt anybody that's
powered on Sugar Sugar well sugar what's
the health was actually a document
documentary on sugar it wasn't about how
that meat was it was like a reverse
documentary on sugar a refer I don't
know if you call it a reverse like a sub
but if you watch it again when they show
sugar and it's just the sugar looks
super clean
yeah so as I State as I State these
things
I know that
I know I have protection
if I have God's protection that's why
I'm here to this date right so it it's
for me to have this platform and express
exactly what I feel because it's kids
out there right that
uh it's kids that are gonna save the
world through engineering and through
facts
and I've got to get download as much of
the information and as much of the don't
be afraid to State your facts is the
biggest thing because the world is being
ran by fear and that is no actually God
runs the world but there's just like
little Cloud this patina of our ego
uh that deals with the money and the car
and the girl we're dating and all this
in the clothes you wear and spending too
much on clothes and a lot of stuff that
I've been involved with promoting so now
what I'm promoting is you have the idea
you say it out loud like you like if you
had Tourette's say your truth out loud
if you hate yay you hate me say that out
loud say whatever you feel
out loud like you say it
non-violently you know non-violent none
of I have to say that like guys you know
you know as a shout out to Alex Jones
you know and Trump where they try to say
that when they say their truths out loud
that it's inciting right and so let's be
like really clear I'm saying that
they have uh criminalized free thought
the you know they I hate when people use
they like they get to blame for
everything right it's always they yeah
oh who who the [ __ ] is that exactly I
promise days us yeah well I love that
what we need to do is turn I to we
so we take the responsibility and turn
they to us so we take accountability
to us
rate I to we and they to us and that
relates it's a language at the same time
you've seen the language of our
surroundings you're seeing the language
of
okay one of one of the things okay let's
go back to the sale explanation because
I'm also doing it what's that thing when
Elon just put all the information open
and people could figure out if they
could figure it out and open source yeah
open source.com open sourcing this idea
right now so that you know
engineers and anointed people uh beings
anointed beings can collectively
contribute to this to push our species
forward
um so where I've got to with my research
is that there will be a hole at the top
that allows natural light
natural air and there's a constant water
system so it becomes like a water city
where it's a constant flow uh that's not
it's it's regenerative it's not wasting
the water and it's just a constant flow
so I put the toilet really close to
where this uh this
um I don't want to call it a wave pool
but in the pool the water is not still
so that exists in in water
he's surrounded by water well the living
room is that you have two rooms you have
the dry room which people will call the
living room before and then you have the
wet room
how's that a source of happiness
what is what is uh broken about our
world today that that gives you in terms
of the pursuit of happiness which is one
of the things well all of our previous
declaration all of our buildings are
based on just
the industry and the economy
and then people lean into what people
are used to seeing
like
what we think is attractive because then
you go back to
the you know women who give life so
everyone wants to be attractive
to the attractive and that's the reason
why the media
goes and gets you know Bella Hadid Kim
Kardashian
uh Emily Ratajkowski
um
those are the only ones I'm gonna uh
there's more there's more but I'm I'm
thinking of ones that I think are
attractive it is subjective yeah because
it's subjective so to my subjective
which I think I think the uh the only
guys that could argue with me on
um on my opinion on girls who'd be Brad
and Leo because we're the only ones with
the track record you know everything
else so for everybody else is subjective
we've got history so
are you are you are you happy
absolutely I'm just here it's actually
it's difficult to make me
unhappy now I could deal with
frustrations
but when those frustrations are it's
like
when you've allowed people to be in your
life that shouldn't be there
and then they do the thing you knew they
were going to do and you're screaming at
them but you really need to scream at
yourself
yeah so you realize anything that's like
anger or frustration that's something
that's wrong with you that needs to be
dealt with
yes like right now okay say I got this
pattern cutter that I wanted
to remove because I felt like she was
copying our patterns into the computer
and I didn't know why she wanted to do
that and I just wanted to do the
patterns by hand
and then you know you mean like
automating the patterns is that yeah and
my head of it because they just that's
the whole thing it's like
it's a war of it's a war of human beings
and robots yeah but that makes it more
efficient right you don't like the
efficiency you like the creativity of
the singular nature of the pattern I
believe that the human beings and I'm
saying this to you as a person who makes
robots and a person is friends
yeah well yeah I'll let it go okay good
so yeah I believe that the yay hates
robots
I'm not gonna put that out it's a joke
robots have feelings too yeah yeah
that's right that was also a joke was it
wouldn't you clarify that for future
robots but the pattern cutter the
pattern cutter you don't like that it
had to be that that's you can't have
that party life
that's not what I'm I'm my
everything that I'm doing is for
okay
the sake of the human race
there's things in capitalism there's
things
and Technology well tech technology and
original human species can exist
in a peaceful way
as long as the people that know how to
make robots aren't using their robots to
control the humans
Lex definitely something you have to be
concerned about as we become more
technologically savvy that my friend is
why engineering isn't everything that
you have to desperately study the
lessons of history in Nazi Germany
science was used to create atrocities
engineering the same engineering could
be a tool of War we are still in the
Holocaust
uh a friend a Jewish friend of mine said
come go visit the Holocaust Museum and
my response was let's visit our
Holocaust Museum Planned Parenthood
with all due respect I grew up in the
Soviet Union
I'm Jewish
parts of my family perished in the in
the Holocaust of Nazi Germany
I have to push back that there is a
difference
of the atrocities at that scale at that
time on an entire piece I was going to
say the number that's the difference
it's not the number because 6 million
will also
African Americans are actually Jew also
the Lost tribe of Israel is back on that
too okay so well everyone came from
Africa I am African I'm basically
African-American we're brothers and
we're both Jew and we're brothers so
we're human six million people died in
the Holocaust over 20 million have died
by the hands of abortion and the media
promotes the my body my choice which is
actually still a promotion for Planned
Parenthood
fifty percent of black deaths
a year is actually abortion it's not
it's not the cop with the knee it's not
black on black violence and gang
violence not heart attacks it's actually
abortion the most dangerous place for a
black person in America is in their
mother's stomach
this 900 to a million abortions in the
United States a year
I hear you
but there's something about
the rape the torture the murder of
children women men the complete complete
humiliation and just the suffering that
was endured during World War II that's
what we deal with on our TVs right now
with black people
Soros would use black trauma economy for
to win an election
and what I love is having a healthy
conversation and as opposed to the
certain things you know boom this drops
people gonna have [ __ ] hats on Boom
this drops is gonna be you know black
people and white people with signs boom
this drops so hey China
hey left agenda hey what we're gonna do
is say that our species can have a
healthy conversation D it's can I just
Linger on this because when you say
Jewish media
it there's a echo of a pain that people
feel that reminds me you're saying it's
redundant right
huh no I'm not saying it's redundant I'm
saying it's redundant you're saying it's
redundant it's already not saying it's
something that you're I'm saying that
it's something that Joseph gerbil's the
propaganda minister of Nazi Germany said
I'm saying it's been said so many times
in order to murder and torture
Jewish people that it just Rings wrong
and that's just like the N word when
spoken by people that have the same skin
color as me it reminds people of a very
dark time I know if if Jewish people
would accept that I'm Jew then they
would see what I'm saying in a different
way they would hear it in a different
way but see the people you saying you're
Jewish that no I'm Jew not Jewish Jewish
means like that of a Jew I'm saying I'm
Jew you're Jew blood of Christ
right but that the are you
um
are you a follower of the philosophy of
the Black Hebrew Israelites
because that's where the idea comes from
not all of those folks are extremists
but some are extremists I'm a follower
of the idea I have a vague idea that all
people came from Africa
but what I wanted to do not okay
now I could Andy Kaufman this about
seven more minutes and then tell you
what it is
let's count seven minutes no I did this
to do a spoiler alert sure spoiler
what's the first thing I said at the
beginning
we're talking about engineering and
humans and then what did I say we
shouldn't focus on Race not just that
I said they shouldn't teach this in
school
history the history because what they do
what schools are doing is exactly what
the CIA does with Pixar films and Disney
films
they make Bambi's mom die in the
beginning right and off that pain comes
a purchase of ice cream off that pain
comes I need some more toys off that
pain comes I need a bigger house off
that pain comes I need more girls than
my wife off that pain comes so they put
that pain in to make us uh now we're the
Orphans of capitalism to make us be
consumers and we need to be a community
not just consumers so I could have went
another seven minutes by being a person
who presents himself in a way that says
well I don't have to feel your pain
because I also have pain too that's not
being recognized and in every interview
when I say well why do I get to the
point of putting up the tweet
uh no one wants to understand why I got
to that point right pain you had pain
yeah but no one in your heart but the
let's say this undoubtedly Jewish people
have a lot of movies about
that pain and black people have a lot of
movies about the pain of slavery right
it's almost impossible to find a movie
about Mansa Musa when you go to the
African history museum in Washington DC
it doesn't start with the idea of
Africans being Kings it starts with the
idea of Africans being slaves but here's
another interesting point about this
this was said to me one time and it
stuck with me as a family member of mine
with Africans how many times you've
heard like a rapper or you know talk
about
we were Kings
that's incorrect
if we're Jew
if we're Jew and since we are we weren't
the Kings we were the slaves that Moses
freed
Africans have always said we've heard
you've listened to rap music and hear
black people say we Kings we blood of
the Pharaohs
and
if we are Jew then we were
we were the people that Moses freed
and when we talk about have you heard
black people talk about 400 years of
slavery all right that is in rep and
we're having this history lesson right
and my history doesn't matter you're
exploring ancient history and drawing
deep wisdom from it and at the same time
saying we need to forget all of it
we need to put that behind us absolutely
we need to forget it and we need to move
forward there's so much wisdom to draw
from history even the 20th century look
at this communism
without the lessons the history of the
20th century communism sounds like a
great idea
except that some of the worst atrocities
conducted by Stalin and Mao that killed
50 hundred plus million people not just
killed tortured starvation where people
the uh cannibalism they hate each other
they ate their children there's there's
just dark people people should read some
books on this on the uh Holland or more
see the 1930s with that lesson we would
and now it's I don't mean more popular
Marxism and communism I'm not
disagreeing that that happened I'm
disagreeing that
we need to harp on the things that
happen because the truth is I'm given a
fact 50 today of
let's say you don't call black people
Jew right black people's deaths today is
abortion today right now like that it's
not racism that's too wide of a term
it's genocide and population control
that black people are in today in
America that is promoted by the music
and the media that black people make
that Jewish record labels get paid off
of or media companies uh regular labels
Media Company also so let's give it a
wider you know I agree with Martin
Luther King
I have a dream too that one day you
would not be judged by the color of your
skin
or your race black or Jew but by the
content in your character all the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] you over in the
music industry [ __ ]
artists over in the music industry are
individuals they're not Jews can you can
you say they are they are Jewish
it doesn't they're human with
opportunities
and they took those opportunities I
don't care if they're Jewish you feel
like I should release that pain and
separate it
yes okay so if that if okay so if you're
saying I should release that pain and
separate it then I'm telling you you
should release your pain and separate it
and we could get to this the list of how
you are being with engineering
opportunities that's 100 I see what
you're doing that exactly you're doing
the pain I'm gonna let it go engineering
challenges I get it one of the problems
you highlight is people get [ __ ] over
in the in the music industry and get
[ __ ] over in the media get [ __ ] over
all over the place they create it there
is a there is a Jewish trainer
that brought me to the hospital and put
in press that I went to the hospital I
got I know friends that off of
exhaustion a Jewish doctor they died
Jewish because they were right diagnosed
me with bipolar disorder and shot me
with medication and put me on medication
then put it in the press and every time
even if I wore the wrong color hat that
a [ __ ] is not supposed to wear right
then they immediately say he's off of
his [ __ ] he's off his meds he's office
rocker and it's literally used as a
Scarlet Letter control mechanism for the
people understand the kids the colleges
the high schools what do you think they
put me right now
they put me as the prophet
not the leader it doesn't have to be the
leader right because we we need we need
more uh intelligent person to be the
leader but at least right they put me as
the prophet they put me as the only
person that would say this and I'm just
saying that was four Jewish members that
controlled my voice because for the fact
that 90 of black people in entertainment
from Sports to music to acting are in
some way tied into Jewish business
people meaning that in some way just
like if if ROM is sitting next to Obama
or Jared sitting next to Trump there's a
Jewish person right there controlling
the the country the Jewish controlling
that who gets the best video or not
controlling what the media says about
the person is not Jewish let me just say
one thing but they are though that's the
only thing it just so happens that they
are it's just you say that doesn't mean
that I hate them yes that just means
that they are but it's a it's a dog
whistle to let me let me just say as I
would love to add more love to the world
I would love you to do that as a person
with a big voice with a big powerful
voice that a lot of people look up to
and when you say Jewish media it's funny
how this world works that way when you
say Jewish Media or Jews are controlling
The Voice
of black artists black people black
artists when you say that I'm not
allowed to say it out loud you can say
it there's a large number of people that
are hurting and have anger and even have
hate in their heart when they hear when
they hear Jewish media they start that
hate Stars being directed towards the
Jewish people
do you acknowledge that that's do you
understand can you feel the hate in the
world that's when that uh that comes to
the surface when you say stuff like that
okay I I feel that
when we go into therapy my dad was a
therapist and obviously I've got some
therapy skills myself a lot of people my
music is healing
these type of spa-like existences or
healing the color palettes I use are
healing and we can use healing words
right
what I really feel there I feel that
there is no accountability and no
responsibility on Jewish people in media
to at least start with owning up with
the facts of what's dealt with and tell
me if I say the facts out loud to the
point of Arya Manuel writing a letter in
the financial times trying to take food
out of my children's mouth telling
people that they're not allowed to work
with me even
Chris uh Como or Pierce Morgan getting
me to apologize and separate
Jewish business people to from the
families of the Jewish business people
which I did update I did that that
already happened and that was a shitty
apology that wasn't really an apology
but shut off that conversation get on my
knees and kiss the dick of Howard Stern
and you don't need to kiss anyone's dick
but that's what you guys are acting like
you guys look at that because you're
talking about it's a shitty uh opinion
uh apology but where's our [ __ ]
apology watch this sorry we don't get
thank you now let's move on sorry oh do
I need to get on my knees or no and kiss
my dick oh [ __ ] so just escalated
quickly so uh that's escalated quickly
so um the uh
so no I'm saying where's our apology but
right we can't get to apology because
you're telling me there's no right way
for me to word it so tell me for me a
person who's been [ __ ] on my deals and
a person has friends that never figured
out how to make shoes with a German
company that couldn't tell me to wear a
BLM shirt and take off my red hat like
what would have happened if I was at
Nike right
um uh tell me exactly how to engineer
the situation I'll tell you exactly how
you got a big voice have the balls as a
man to call out the individuals don't
call them Jews call them by their name
and start a war against those
individuals they're not Jewish but if
that's the case
will you help me with that sure okay 100
[ __ ] are asking well let me like
flip that too I don't understand the
industry well I I I see that people are
[ __ ] people over for sure but how do
you solve that if you run if you right
now run the world's uh you're doing a
million things but say you ran also a
record label
I have ran a record like oh I've been
ran by a record label where I was the
face of a record label and had Big Sean
of different people complaining to me
and I knew [ __ ] about running a record
label I was simply just a talented
producer and an influencer yes that then
started good music but I wasn't the one
running good music how would you do it
differently this is something I I
propose I would look at
the top 10 execs and three fields in
sports
uh film and music
and I would look at the top 10
uh clients participant act talent I
would look at the top talent in each of
those field the top 10 of them and some
of them are going to be Tom Brady some
of them are going to be Taylor Swift
some of them they're not all going to be
black right some of them so
uh some of them would be Adele right uh
and
will look at all their contracts
transparently and will compare the notes
and re-engineer like it's a new
constitution because when I told my dad
when I was 19 I was going to get into
the music industry he begged me not to
he said I heard it's treacherous
now I'm in a position where I've been
through it I saw it I went out made some
money somewhere else I saw my name get
smeared I saw my family get destroyed I
saw my reputation get destroyed and I'm
back here to have this kind of I'm back
here as a being with engineering
opportunities so I would say if you say
as a shitty apology what is the version
uh of the apology short of kissing
Howard Stern's dick
I don't think anyone wants to kiss
Hollis turns down that's the whole point
Howard Stern nobody wants to kiss your
dick so shut the [ __ ] up I said by the
way I'm antagonize you Howard Stern I
used to be a fan of you
yeah me too yeah not still a fan
sometimes now now you're just doing
click bait like everybody else
now you're just a sad old man Howard all
right
now Howard Stern this is the first time
anyone's said your name in years your
own family doesn't say your name unless
they're calling to get their bills paid
you're going hard
see that's beautiful right there that's
much better than calling Jewish media
call go after individuals okay so after
individuals and you don't talk [ __ ]
about me talk [ __ ] about me this is
great and you know what that is yeah
what's that
engineering that's an engineer's
approach yeah Engineers yeah yeah you
should learn some of that we all can use
our pain against each other or we can
say we're being
with engineering opportunities and we
can know about history so let me change
something
we can have
a just to be judgmental people say thou
should not judge I was talking to
Camille Vasquez she says I'm very
judgmental that's what we're doing we I
I I believe now you could go to Bible
and one thing's gonna say one thing
another thing may be contradicted in a
way and then the pastor has to unpack it
I believe
that we are to judge if you look at some
food and it's got a fly coming out of it
you can then judge at that point you're
supposed to use your better judgment but
whenever someone doesn't want to change
something they're doing they'll say
Don't Judge Me Right But as a species
you call it for me you got the
Breakthrough and by the way it's only an
engineer that I would respect to tell me
of how of how to update how I'm
communicating because this started off
right I've been through all these
um interviews
let me go to this you said this was a uh
sorry apology I was very specific I said
the Jewish Because by the way it's a
barrage right it's a thing where I don't
even remember the names at a certain
point right it's like if a if a girl was
getting raped by men
if that person's not 18 right
and she was getting raped since 14 right
and she still got this face this super
like Irina Shake level face right uh
she might say
I hate men
that woman may say I hate men she might
get to that point because she was raped
all my contracts and no one can say this
is ramped up knowing Howard Stern can't
say this is wrapped up our Emmanuel
can't say this is wrapped up George
Soros knows damn well that I'm not
ramped up your Sorrows knows like wow
this guy's like a younger
guy that's looking at what I did and
looking at how I control the world
silently and he's calling it out and
he's not using any of the fear tactics I
can't send his homeboys around him I
can't send his wife to him this guy
that's what George Sorrel sees right
when he's dealing with me right so what
you guys are actually asking me to do
I'm comparing myself to that 18 year old
beautiful
a woman that had been mistreated by men
for uh four years of her life right and
you're saying you know as a man you
can't blame all men and I'm saying as a
responsible
uh forward philosopher leader
okay I'll drop the pain and I will
specify because I'm up here
I lost my [ __ ] family I lost my kids
I lost my best friend in fashion I lost
I lost the black community I lost you
know people said I lost my mind all of
these things lost my reputation and I'm
up here just like I just want my family
but I don't want my family to have to
say what the left wants us to say I to
have to say what China wants to say I
want to be an American and protect my
kids and protect my wife and raise my
kids as Christians and have my wife be a
Christian and innovate and American-made
rock and roll I want to innovate as a
creative person and be a successful
American but all of that have been taken
away from me so I'm coming back and I'm
removing the pstd right now right I'm
standing up and saying the only way that
we're going to be able to get past this
and the way God is going to
um
use me right now as for me to stop
talking about the pain stop talking
about what happened and do something
about it and that's where I'm at right
now in this moment like yeah people
agree at least there was something where
you could say he has a reason of why he
got to that tweet and what you're doing
for me today is saying
yo uh that was a sorry apology and let's
specify I'm not asking for anyone out
here to empathize or sympathize for a
you know a dude worth 11 billion dollars
that can make money disappear I mean uh
appear at a thin air in five different
Industries you know I'm not asking for
the I'm not asking anybody to sympathize
with someone who's married to Kim
Kardashian dated Irene and shake like I
I feel like I'm just not gonna get the
sympathy vote in this situation right so
I feel your pain I feel yeah I feel like
No One's Gonna feel my pain only only
Brad and Leo can fill my paint right so
the so uh uh but still but here today
when you said is a sorry apology
what's the what's the apology that
you're looking for as a as a Jewish
engineer I'm not say as Lex let's not
talk about you being Jewish as Lex
what's the apology
that you want me to say to am I allowed
to say Jewish tell me is it anti-semitic
for Yea to say Jewish out loud no
there's uh I don't like the allowed that
presumes censorship I think you choose
if you have a powerful voice did I prove
did I did I prove that there was
censorship over the past two weeks who
censored you oh drink Champs oh my Lord
oh like Twitter and so on Twitter that
has less to do drink Champs that hurt
you the drink Champs uh that Noah took
it down took down your conversation oh
it didn't hurt you
man you got to be honest about that
we're still the kids we used to be
I put my hand on the stove to see if I
still bleed
and nothing hurts anymore I feel kind
free
no do you think
you know I I went to Japan for two to
three months right
the day
I had Sunday service my kids are
supposed to be there and my kids would
know where to be found and I text Kim
and said where are my kids we get into
an argument
and then I get a text from a number I
don't know and it's Pete Davidson
bragging about being in bed with my wife
then
just [ __ ] with you well at that point
it's like
they're trying to put me in jail or put
a friend of mine in jail
because then I'm gonna go surround the
hotel
and do all you know do something which
would have me not be able to be here
and instead I walked away from that
situation I went to Japan like the
samurai that I am and went to the top of
the mountain and
because I knew that I mean I knew there
was no way
she could love this dude not just
because she's ugly he's not black she
likes black guys every guy that she you
know is with looks exactly the same Ray
J uh Reggie Bush
at that time Kanye West she has a type
just like how I have a type like a lot
of my girls look kind of similar to her
because in a video game character people
have people have their type right so I
knew that this was like the princess has
a type and she likes Mario
right there you go as somebody cares for
you and hopefully can be a friend
yay I gotta say these words and the
words about Jews is not the words of a
samurai
of a great man I would say you know you
said
something that inspired that resonated
with a lot of people when you said
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
I have to say as somebody who cares for
you that yay the artist formerly known
as Kanye West
doesn't care about Jewish people
in the same way you spoke about George
Bush being a politician and not giving a
[ __ ] about the poor people that suffered
after Katrina you're not giving a [ __ ]
about the suffering of the Jewish people
across the world wow why am I not
because you're feeding you're giving
strength motivation we already updated I
gave an apology you said it wasn't good
enough yeah that's right and now you're
telling me no I'm not gonna you don't
need to kiss anyone's dick well yeah
you're asking me to kiss to say it was
wrong to say there's no Jewish media
there's no Jewish uh there isn't there's
no control of the media by Jewish you're
an engineer brother if you're an
engineer and you're not holding to the
truth that's not engineering engineering
is not that's not that doesn't that's
hate that's not engineering I'm gonna
build a better record label it's called
said I'm going to respect stereotypes
exist for a reason Engineers don't do
stereotypes they're types are dumb they
allow you to channel hate towards the
other you know what the biggest thing is
yeah
with a something of Veteran that was
sitting next to me at Cheesecake Factory
last night
uh he said
you know the the general Justice he
serves for whoever is the president
right and he said what's happening in
politics is
we're forgetting we're on the same side
we're forgetting around this this is
someone is practically now he's a nurse
so he's still you know fighting for
Humanity in a way he went from holding
you know guns in battle to being a a
nurse and uh when people are battling
for their lives and he said we're
forgetting we're on the same side this
is a person that no matter who becomes
president he can still be told to go to
war
and the chaos that's created by the
media
has split the country
in half and what we what us as being so
the engineer opportunity need to do
right now is fine the blue water
where do we where are places that we
agree on and I want you to finish
everything hey I'ma let you finish
everything I've said before you want to
express to me get off all I'm yours I'm
your scarecrow today I'm your I'm your
punching bag today for everything I did
and I want you to stand up for all of
the hate that I'm your Al Gore when he
lost the election remember he almost
became a punching bag for the lady that
had voted on him and she just said all
this stuff and he's like I know I agree
with you right but there's nothing you
know that he could do about it with this
it's like things that you're saying I
agree with you you know it's like if you
sit some kids in the um in the
principal's office and I punched
somebody right I took I took my hand
right as
what it really means even Arya Emmanuel
had to say this is a pop icon right and
I went and just punched
an entire people at one time or said
that I was about to I went like this
right and I got blacked out black
mirrored done right and it's like what
were you even gonna do and why did you
go like this
I went like this
because
I I can't even do I would I would look
insane to physically show you
a metaphor a a a physical representation
of my last 20 years
of what I've been through
as a musician
as a father and as a black person with a
political opinion a great man still
through the pain does the right thing
and I think the right thing
is to not say that there's Jewish
control of the media that's incorrect
though that's a [ __ ] lie there is and
they did come and Bully me it proved the
point no the reason you don't say it is
because the world is much bigger than
the forgive me the narrow little world
you exist in your impact stretches way
past those little boardroom meetings
over contracts so what should I have
done what should I have done not say
that you should no be a strong man that
doesn't mention that doesn't match a
religion to people and then fight do you
want to win this fight how do we win
call out individual people build that's
one way because they have a big voice
the other voice that I prefer is to
build another uh uh label I feel or
supportive you're controlling my
creative narrative and my because just
like how you're telling me I shouldn't
have said that do you think there were
people telling me I shouldn't have wore
a red hat
no you because you asked me what should
I have done you're supposed to be a
scarecrow so I thought I'm gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of the Scarecrow with my
words right you let me yeah it was
consensual the punching bag is about
because scarecrow actually has a
different yeah
punching bag I can't say a scarecrow
yeah but every single person that I've
sat with from the point when I wore the
red hat till now has done the same thing
sit in the principal's office and don't
do what you're doing we're in the
General's closet right now together and
I'm not the red hat is very different
the red hat is uh you have a set of
beliefs you represent half the country
that has a a hope a vision for the
future of America that's very different
than without any purpose whatsoever
saying Jewish media Jewish control of
the media you said there's no purpose so
you're taking away my history and my
reason of what my purpose was
I'm saying awesome also also I'm
speaking my voice vocalizing also yeah
it's God's plan there's a lot of things
that open up let me tell you something
that opened up there's a guy like I told
you that was running stem player who
I've had issues with we hadn't got paid
on certain things right and he took his
his IQ his no highest engineering uh
know how to he basically was trying to
Adidas me with even though I was the
bigger money in the situation that was
fun and we funded together and he hired
these engineers and he said well because
your comments we're not going to be able
to hire anybody else and I was like well
how many Jewish people do we have in our
company said I don't know he didn't say
exactly right I said do we have black
people he said yeah since then how many
said two
so we have like 60 full-time employees
like 40 halftime and part-time and
I
I took as a responsibility let's let's
let's take a step back from the US being
one species and say hey you're Jewish
I'm black right why step back for this
example for the sake of this example and
I said wow
I'm sure I could hire more than two
black engineers
and what happens is
because there are so many businessmen
that just so happen to be Jewish that
it's good business right just to
monopolize that's what people are
looking everybody wants to be Elon right
so
uh the I disagree with that okay but let
me finish this point
um I'll let you finish a lot of a lot of
businessmen want to be as successful as
Elon and as popular as Elon a lot I
could just worded like that which I hate
the term a lot actually I want to be
more specific but I don't I haven't done
the math on it but say some factually
for sure there are some business people
of all different walks and backgrounds
that would like to be as rich and as
popular as Elon Musk so let me just take
a step back from the weird one species
into the we're separated by race gender
socioeconomic class conversation and say
as a black owner of two Tech platforms
hardware and software I need to take
action let's not call it affirmative
let's just say I need to take action and
uh I need to take accountability and
ensuring
that
black engineers
are hired and guess what hired together
because when the black people that are
brilliant are separated from our culture
we forget who we are and we'll get to a
point where you know uh OJ said I'm not
black I'm OJ because just to be on the
golf course we put on the golf shirt but
the golf shirt might not be something
that our culture would have done and now
our culture and uh poor communities is
oh everybody's got Draco on them
everybody's got a gun on them oh if you
run up on me on the gas station imma
kill you hey you ain't got to talk to me
like a man if I haven't killed at least
five people but you know what happens is
we can kill five people we could kill 10
people and still be in the media as long
as we play by the the rules right
because what will happen is any of these
guys that have talked about killing
people and different things unless
trumpet pardon them right but let's say
even if Trump pardon them they could
still go to Someone Like A a little
boozy or Meek Mills or Puff Daddy
anybody and say hey we need you to talk
[ __ ] about yay right now and also you're
not allowed if you do want to vote for
Trump or vote outside of what this
Arrangement is then we're going to put
you in jail
it ain't no we're not gonna bring you
down we have this on you you get I'm
saying if I had ever killed someone if I
wasn't the [ __ ] with the pink Polo on I
wouldn't be able to be the vocal man
that I am today you understand what I'm
saying this is the reason why I'm happy
that my Gangster Disciple Brothers kept
me from the initiations which made me
feel like a [ __ ] my whole life right
but now I am someone who legally can say
this other people in my position they
legally cannot speak
they legally cannot speak
or they will go to prison
I am in a bit of a Glass Prison because
I don't have say so of where my children
go to school
but I'm in a freedom place where I can
have this conversation with you right
now and that is
I I don't like the word breakthrough you
know that that's God's hand on this
situation
but you get what I'm saying about if I
hadn't said the tweet I wouldn't have
had to take the accountability myself to
hire black Engineers into my two Tech
platforms yeah and you get what I'm
saying that's beautiful personal Journey
you're on but you get what I'm saying
it's not personal it's for my people as
a whole as a tribal company it's a small
company as a tribal person
I believe that I am my people
yeah and and the thing that that
businessmen have done to my people have
pulled the brightest out of our tribes
and siled them and made us lose our
culture and lose who they were all the
only thing I wanted to say at Virgil's
funeral which I wasn't allowed to
right it was a white Pastor that talked
the majority of the funeral half the
funeral was pissed pissed right
um and uh and this pastor actually
married me and Kim right he looks like
Justin Timberlake a little bit uh and
um
he talked half the funeral he knew
Virgil's passing did a collaboration
with him before he passed by the way
right a clothing collaboration I didn't
know Virgil was passing but the thing I
wanted to say
I saw ASAP Rocky and I saw some other
members of his gang
you know in the audience at the funeral
and all I wanted to tell him is don't
let them split the gang up
don't let them split the gang up
when
I did the first Yeezy uh because I did
Kanye West two fashion shows before as a
high-end luxury all leather kind of
designer not all leather but you know
high-end materials
um
mink this kind of thing
um
and then I came back
with Yeezy with Adidas and this fashion
show was so popular that Justin Bieber
had to sit in the second row right this
thing had every name you could think of
it had
Kim Kardashian Kris Jenner Kendall
Jenner it was Kylie's First fashion show
she'd been in and in the second fashion
show I put Kylie and Bella Hadid next to
each other in the fashion show you had
Puff Daddy at that time Puff Daddy
uh had beef with Drake Drake still came
to the show and Jay-Z had to break up
the fight backstage the designers you
had Jerry Lorenzo that's had a fear God
you had Kim shrub head of scams you have
Virgil ablo Head of Louis Vuitton you
had dimna head of Balenciaga all working
for
yay for the leader for the philosopher
right for the person that put who put
this together me that's who right you
had these people working for the king in
New York basically the boss yay right
you had you had Jay-Z in the audience
Rihanna in the audience
um Beyonce in the audience sitting next
to Anna winter in this audience and
guess who her wind of this
one of the richest men in the world
Bernard Arnold caught wind of this
what's going on they're building up
something and we need to stop it so then
he met with me and politely offered me
backing for my clothing line
it would be Kanye West they would get 49
a 51 I would get 49 they'd have control
and they were going to give me all of
the support from Louis Vuitton uh so I
had to go to Adidas and I told Adidas
hey let's identify the apparel uh so
Adidas you're not gonna do the apparel
anymore hey we had a we had a good time
but we're gonna run off with Gisele now
right so the that's like you told your
girl that and you're like oh no we're
supposed to we have the proudest moment
of our career and so so
uh so then he offers me the deal and
Alexander Arno who's went to gone on and
rape and pillage from all of the talent
that I had afterwards said I say before
I tell Adidas to indemnify the apparel
can I get a written contract from your
dad Bernard Arno and he says my dad will
never go back on his word you so you
already know what this thing is going
right you can spoiler alert right uh he
went back on his word so three months
into the deal I get Anna winter
I say who should I use for my lawyer she
picks my lawyer for me right I just
found out even a couple of days that the
lawyer demanded an airplane during
negotiations had nothing to do with me
right they said that Bernardino got
freaked out and then Alexander no calls
me and says the deal got dropped at the
board
I went back and told my high maintenance
wife
I was supposed to become this designer
at Louis Vuitton or the Louis Vuitton
group was going to back the Kanye West
line because that's how good I've done
in fashion babe
and now the deal is dropped
now the deal is dropped so then I did a
second collection
and we didn't have any support to be
able to build the collection then I went
and found in third collection we did it
we took over MSG fourth collection went
and the show started an hour late
then a week later Kim got robbed then I
told scooter Braum my manager at that
time I say I
uh I'm looking you know I need to go to
Japan I'm tired I'm tired he says no you
need to make more money
I
do four more shows on a second leg of
the tour
and I suffer from exhaustion and go to
the hospital and then get diagnosed with
the disorder this is the first time I
ever suffered from exhaustion by the way
I haven't been to the hospital since
I haven't been to the hospital since and
haven't taken you know medication in two
years and I'm sure there will be people
in the media we won't say where phone
will say well that's obvious right so
um so right now I'm talking to you right
I'm not on medication I just go to sleep
right I have sleep have you been able to
sleep this uh that's that's that's
that's that's too low hanging fruit for
you you're you're more you're uh I agree
I expect more I agree that was dumb I
regret it that that's like uh that's
like Pierce Morgan trying to grab
ratings and stuff like you got a whole
life ahead of you you got a whole life
ahead of you yeah these guys are at the
end of their life oh good good so this
is out of my [ __ ] I love it but then
amidst that the same guy that dropped my
deal Bernard I know goes and hires my
best friend
goes and hires my main engineer right it
would have been like them hiring
you know Elon from Peter before they
figured out Paul before they figured out
PayPal but it tolerance I was like uh it
all pal sounds like Paul I just said
because I'm a Christian I thought it was
cool but it would have been like what if
someone could have went in and took Elon
away from Peter before they pay Paul
before they I just could say PayPal yeah
it's just too close yeah too close it
just sounds so fresh to the fact that
it's so close right and that's that's
what happened right they broke the gang
up and I'm telling you right now
that hadn't happened Virgil's alive I'm
still married you know I'm saying the
power structure was broken then right
because we're building some Kylie wasn't
a billionaire that you know I mean we
were building something together that a
French colonizer came in
and caught it early
and tried to destroy it but the only
thing is God is alive and I'm anointed
and even with those drawbacks losing my
wife losing my friend uh uh exhaustion
um all of these late night tweets that
piss off an entire group you know like
this
the frustration still there
we work I work for God and God runs the
world and we'll see what we'll see what
happens but in those words don't you
feel that
being split up don't you feel you're
doing the thing that you stand against
which is playing victim
aren't you playing
victim to the forces in the world I
didn't get a chance to play I just said
I was about to I said like this like no
you played pretty damn well what do you
mean what do you what do you mean about
to you're like one of the greatest
designers in history fashion designers
what you're playing you are playing what
is that even I thought I thought you're
referring to the tweet
yeah
well there's a full
set of things that you're under attack
for
the tweet and everything beyond that but
like you're you're blaming not blaming
but you're saying that the Jewish media
the Jewish record labels the Jewish
people forget Jewish or not it doesn't
matter is playing victim
right
ultimately I am fighting a battle in the
spiritual form and anyone that believes
in God and is looking at this interview
would agree with that and I just so
happen to be a bright part of God's Army
I'm fighting for us to live the greatest
gift is life itself I am pro-life
I am pro-god I believe that Jesus Christ
is our Lord and savior and died for our
sins
what do you feel about
another attack another painful thing I
imagine super painful is Balenciaga
pulling um
uh
you had a really close relationship and
friendship with their uh creative
director
like how do you feel about all of it
I told you I sang the song I'll sing
another song from one of my mentors
future I never feel pain
I haven't felt too much pain
like there was a day where I was headed
to Nashville to meet with George farmer
who is the CEO of parlor the the day
when we made the announcement
at that same day
uh Balenciaga
uh was taking my imagery off of their
site
and uh the drink Champs was being taken
down
and I said this is the happiest day of
my life
I love cutting the grass low
people wasn't really with you they was
part-time people switch up when it's
wartime I'd rather have people who are
really with me and not people who are
just trying to use me listen as a friend
somebody cares for you you have to be
really careful by the People by all
people always the people that are going
to be try to be close to you now you
don't know if you can trust them anymore
oh what the blitzy I got I have more to
say about it though yeah
let's do this
dimna will still work
for yay someday and this is just
speeding the process up
have you talked can you share if you've
talked yes I'll I talked to dimna this
is like we're Kendrick Spirits none of
this can keep us away from each other I
brought dimna to Gap to be able to bring
the best product in the world at that
time I wanted to go under a hundred
dollars now I'm like okay we're gonna go
20 a product uh I brought dimna in
to engineer that's why I said engineer
by Balenciaga easy guy I'm engineered by
Balenciaga to engineer the best product
for the people the people that
that they say are at the bottom of the
Maslow hierarchy of need
chart they're at the bottom of the
pyramid right so
Gap didn't want that Balenciaga didn't
want that
our agendas were not aligned I was
brought in
to the gap for political reasons and
influence like a Virgil like a George
Floyd
when popular celebrities are brought
into Fortune 500 companies is not to
raise the stock it's to strengthen the
position and influence
and is definitely not to be out here
letting a [ __ ] think he's Steve Jobs
yeah there's people like that
but you as a great man a visionary
your job
is to understand that game and be one
step ahead
well that's why I'm telling them that
relationship you know some relationships
only last for a summer
yeah you know some last for a year the
relationship ran its course
you know
in that relationship I invested a lot of
my social capital and actual Capital
that I spent somewhere between five to
ten million dollars personally on
Balenciaga
how much money do you think Balenciaga
had paid me in the past two years
just take a really wild guess a really
wow less than that
just take a super wild one
just go to the furthest extent of your
imagination
1.2 million
lower
five hundred thousand lower
zero zero all right and actually two
weeks ago I paid at a Saints account
eight hundred and sixty two thousand
dollars not in close for me from
Balenciaga from the store in royalties
to Balenciaga where the deal had been
engineered where I was coming out of my
pocket so I paid last year I paid demna
three million dollars
to
uh to design The Collection right and we
got it out of the Gap marketing fund and
he was going to deliver 160 skus or 120
skus 100 skus are separate items of
clothing uh so
uh styles of clothing
so we ended up delivering about 60.
well I feel like we're on the People's
Court because we actually are right
we're in the court of public opinion
uh so he delivered about 60. there were
all kinds of people that were working
part of the reason why I had to get
dimna like I didn't want to have to I
wanted to compete with him I don't want
to have to like get him you know when I
made stronger I did it to compete with
Timberland and and Justin Timberlake
because my fiance at that time like
Justin Timberlake just a little bit too
much so I made it to compete and then we
had the song out it's number one on
Apple it's blowing up I play it in a
club and it sounds muddy it doesn't
sound the way
Sexy Back sounded in the club so I go to
Pharrell
Williams to to do the drums and it
doesn't it sounds like a different
record I know it can't be a different
record because I'm like I'm gonna swap
it out on radio right then I go to Swiss
beats it sounds like a different record
I go to Timberland the person who did
sexy back
and he did he did it
in five minutes and then spent the rest
of the hour talking about how nobody
could have done it except for him
running around the studio I'm the best
no what could it that's why he had to go
to me had to go to the king well he had
a point right he had a point right so
what makes us some money is it the beat
it was in the drums it was something
that Timberland had in those drums like
now watch this
I said I'm going Defcon 3 right and the
actual I spelled it wrong I have a
tendency to do that I'm not quite John
Legend tight sweater level spelling B
level so I feel a parallel to me going
to Timberland
to when I said hey you as an engineer I
need to work with you as an engineer
that is Jewish
to look at these contracts and what my
people
not just black people let's say artists
are dealing with in our contracts these
contracts need to be fixed everyone
could be so mad at the messenger right
yay you said it the wrong way you're
offensive you're like Hitler now because
you said it you said this out loud but
it does not you're you weren't getting
enough sleep all this [ __ ] does not
negate the fact
that we do have Houston we have a
problem
yeah but we it's just the music industry
like there's a lot of hate that was
created by just saying that you know but
you're saying what is just is everything
to me right yeah yeah one one person
would do everything to me right and for
George Bush winning an election was
everything and then when you said George
Bush doesn't care about black people
that you woke him up you woke the people
up to the fact that he was narrowly
being selfish you are there's a sense to
which you're being corrupted by your own
greatness that you're focusing too much
on the industry that you've made great
that you've Rose to the very top one of
the richest artists in history one of
the greatest designers I'm not I am the
richest artist in history
probably the richest artist in history
yeah they say the funny thing is they're
like oh riches black person's like oh
also richest actor richest musician
richest fashion designer like is a bunch
of riches in that one yeah I'm saying
it's like richer than Ralph Lauren like
like richer than Amani like richest like
of that but still low because where do
you put that you know like on the totem
because I don't even want to uh man's
bank account isn't everything
I would say you and I are equal
in a certain deep sense
no matter what the bank account says
so I wanted to give you some theme music
for uh for yourself a little muddy let
me give you the Timberland version
thank you
okay so other thing about like say like
Balenciaga is
will work with yay someday and
for Cedric and for Francois Pino and
Selma's is a beautiful human being
five years from now
you'll hear and know the name yay and no
things that we did
and
Balenciaga is not going to make it onto
your questions
would you what would you as a Gambling
Man Would you bet on that I will bet on
that I can see it in your eyes
so it was sad it was actually a sad day
for me not for me but more for
Balenciaga
I just when when I heard that I was just
like
oh shame
let me ask you a silly question just uh
about them I read something that YouTube
talked about like buttons for a few
hours
they're my gum drop buttons
just another accent me and dim only
speaking Shrek what what's your
philosophy uh with which you approached
design you're you are one of the great
fashion designers of our time how do you
think about it do you have a philosophy
you know what I like about the zipper is
this zipper the zipper hoodie replaces
the dress shirt
because you could get on your douchebag
[ __ ] and like unzip it and give a little
bit of you know that type of look and
which is the douchebag you know like
when the when the you know the
douchebags that go to Vegas and unbutton
their dress shirt yeah yeah and the
problem with the pullover hoodie is
you can't do the douchebag thing when
you unbutton it but then still get the
like the stomach because the thing is
the ultimate look would be like
you know military tank
pull over hoodie and if you get a little
hot you take off the hoodie but you're
like crazy in shape
so it gives you that flexibility yeah
it's giving the zippers giving some
flexibility and it's like maybe you want
to keep your jacket on like it's
considered like a hoodie to be like a
jacket if you want to keep your jacket
on then
you might you might want to do this as
opposed to pulling it all the way off
yeah you know so
and it's just Comfort but then you get
okay
can I do a jogging pant on this with a
last elasticity now people argue about
climate uh where we are with the climate
I take a responsibility as being the
most influential
um
designer yeah of all time uh to
um
to say we're going to use biodegradable
uh clothing now the issue there is
um
the elastic
is not biodegradable
so that means it's actually better to
use genes and a belt
than to have an elastic waistband
because elastic waistband is not
biodegradable
so I use the planet
as a big the future of the planet is a
big piece of
the way I Engineer and the way we talk
about where designs are going the
constraints on your design and
Engineering is given by the planet by
the future of the planet yes
that could almost make Jewish people
like me again
every time you say Jewish people I think
I've been maybe reading a little too
much about World War II but man I'd
recommend you listen to some uh
audiobooks or read some books on the
Holocaust because like
it's heavy it's heavy it will put into
context which impact of your words uh
would you read books on the current
Holocaust that black people are in don't
I mean I read uh what have you read
about abortion I've read
um a lot of short form writing and I've
listened to a lot of debates because
it's really humbling
that the the question of when does Life
Begin
is a really difficult question
for me as an engineer and scientist
it's a philosophical question I mean we
could just go on population control not
like if abortion is right or wrong we
could say factually
the clinics were made by eugenics
for population control and it is
controlling the population as is the
never being given of 40 acres in a mule
so you don't have the opportunity and
when the people that do have the
opportunity are separated from our
people our tribe and placed in Suburban
communities next to us Chris rocker put
it the dentist and you know whitewashed
and made to shut the [ __ ] up and you
know vote left or whatever you know uh
[ __ ] are supposed to do when we make
it as opposed to
saying okay
we're building
schools we're building up choirs we're
building up our own leagues basketball
teams our own factories we started the
first
uh sportswear factory in America since
World War II
was actually uh this Factory I put in
Cody so
you know I'm 45 years old we're on this
journey right now it's the other thing
about this it's like
people just in general they love me so
much I'm like actually a hard guy to
really hate for a long period of time
it's just because like because of like
my huge [ __ ] and that's what I noticed I
didn't I didn't understand why he showed
it to me when we first met but now I
understand
yeah it's very nice congratulations
uh I know you don't talk about it but
your hat does say 24. yeah
um if you run for president what kind of
ideas would you represent
that we're beings with engineering
opportunities
I would represent
just as you served a platform here
there's something that happened on my
last run that
I thought I feel I know was brilliant it
was noisy but it was brilliant
I had one rally
and in the rally I just let people come
up and I gave them a platform
it's our responsibility to listen to the
pain and hear the pain and understand
even when
we're the ones that cause the pain like
with my tweet it's my responsibility to
hear you and understand why you feel
like that but it's our responsibility as
the people to understand each other
to give people a voice
people need the voice and even right now
what I'm doing or how God is using me
I'm showing where our voices are being
muted there's
professors that are actually intelligent
actually have multiple degrees that have
been canceled
from their schools
and they don't have a music industry or
a fan base or shoe design or a smoking
hot ex-wife to complain about they've
just got the truth of what they saw and
what they dedicated to this country and
to education that has been muted by
schools that have been taken over with
an agenda and so you're you want the
brightest Minds to be these professors
and then you mute them and they have
nowhere to go and you might get a guy
now that went from being someone's
favorite Professor to he's working at
Starbucks like like he was back at
school or like he was back in high
school
so even if that voice is about anger and
Hate
it still deserves to be heard
yeah it deserves to be heard and we
deserve to ask why you know like you
have to ask why I just feel like that's
what's I feel like that is sympathizing
Mr huge [ __ ] I'm just saying
and that
it just needs to be
I should change that to your name on
Twitter
while you're still allowed on there yeah
I do you think that that would get
censored I feel like they you know they
definitely cut it down some inches uh
the
I'm I'm pointing out this
I'm pointing out this truth no I'm sorry
this is not a Christian thing right uh
and
you know I wonder right there when I say
these jokes
is it something that I because I do feel
like laughter is the key engineering and
laughter right is the key to
peace like when I go get my teeth clean
and I have the nitrous there's uh
there's something that I want to go and
hug Kris Jenner I want to go and hug
Corey Campbell I want to go and hug you
know Howard I'm not no one wants to hug
Howard Stern you know but you know just
if one no no no let's I think I would
love to see you two hug it out and make
up even though all the [ __ ] talking back
and forth what about talking it out or
is he going to be screaming at me
yeah judgmental and that kind of stuff
no I hope I hope there's love there you
know the thing is
I think Howard's just jealous
you know yeah not just uh not just
jealous of my [ __ ] he's also
um
he's jealous that I started my campaign
earlier than him
you gotta let go of that jealousy you
gotta let go of that jealousy Howard you
gotta hold everybody else is a natural
human thing man I wonder just as a
Christian right when I joke and say this
stuff I
it's like hmm am I being disobedient to
God because as a boss right I'll talk to
um
and uh an employee and I'll be like why
didn't you just listen because I've got
the bigger plan right so
it's like me talking to God were there
things that I did in this interview that
were disobedient to God and and for
those things I I pray and I repent for
anything that I've said that was
disobedient to God but humor is not one
of them joking I feel like humor is the
way we avoid so much suffering in the
world it's the way to it's like a
catalyst for love like it's a way to
people that gone through some of the
darkest trauma that I've ever met
through War I just came back from
Ukraine
They're laughing
they're they're making jokes that's the
best way to deal with dark times I don't
know what it is about like humans I feel
like humor
that's the best way to social engineer a
good future I think is humor not taking
[ __ ] too seriously that's the problem
with censorship one of the things that
really suffer is humor jokes maybe going
too far in the jokes you mentioned
Anthony jeselnick that guy goes hard
that guy goes really hard and it's great
he crosses all he crosses all the lines
and he's that's why he's a genius and
that's what people feel is refreshing
when he does it
I don't know what it is but then it's
like hurtful when I do it but I tell you
something that was interesting I'm
pretty sure
Anthony doesn't like sorry for the
assumption but just most comedians I
know didn't vote for Trump
that's interesting I'm not saying there
aren't comedians that did but just the
ones I know because I live in California
right but they have an appreciation for
Trump because of the sense of humor yeah
gotta ask you about parlor and
Engineering because I'm interested about
that
hey man I'm actually trying to hold it
together you're pretty you're pretty
offensive towards towards a lot
and I'm not looking to be offensive I
really want to bring people together and
get these things done but the War I 100
I see your vision how do we do it
somebody you care if well not don't say
Jewish media and Jewish Jewish
controlled media JM
like man you saw you sound like it it
sounds too much like 1930s Nazi Germany
that was leading up to the atrocities oh
he would say JM yeah he was brand to JM
that's right no it's just the the the
implied like this um memified
uh
Prejudice towards a group in a way
that's going to lead to hate and I I
know you don't mean that I know I know
you have love in your heart you know as
a Prejudice towards a group that led to
hate
BLM
BLM took a black person
showed his death on camera
because okay
there are examples of
us being killed and being killed on
camera but if it was spread on camera it
was done on purpose by the media because
14 20 kids get killed in Chicago every
week and it's not spread that much they
like you said
singled out a person
directed everything on that person right
as the Martyr and
raise the people that hadn't had any we
didn't have our 40 acres of the mule we
didn't have you know like a lot of
things right like that black people have
not ever been given so once we've given
just a little bit like
your life matters right then we
literally like oh okay now we're being
heard
right but
actually the deaf toll is up the city uh
where this happened is completely been
turned to a war zone they actually
it's actually something like Candace
Owens can actually
specify this better but it's like its
own City or something like they they
made it not be a part of the actual
state or something that's like like DC
and stuff it's like it's like Washington
DC now and stuff like and that has to be
from a government
you know that's got
higher level agenda written all over it
yeah they're using the death of an
individual yeah sure the media are not
the Jewish media the media and that's
the media is [ __ ] up that machine
does takes whatever tragedy and uh
pushes it towards whatever narrative
that gets more clicks and Views and so
on sure and then politicians do the same
they use the media to influence the
media to tell a story and
um I this is a simple thing I'll put I
believe that
the idea of anti-Semitism and
the the closeness of uh the Holocaust
is used by
certain individuals and media to not
take accountability for
the bad things that that are happening
and
what's happened is there's a new
frontier right meaning like it used to
be okay for somebody to be a billionaire
we thought about a billion a billionaire
right you a lot of times you think I'm
actually kind of being out of shape and
you know 20 years ago 30 years ago like
Onassis or something like you thought
about a different way now you think
about it but you think about Elon you
think Kim think yeah you think
it's a new kind of billionaire you know
it's not just Sorrows this is a
billionaire it's a new form of
billionaire we'll
right now what I'm calling for the
industry is I'm I'm calling I'm calling
the industry out and saying like hey it
just so happens that
there's been times where I had my lawyer
was Jewish my regular was Jewish but
like like eight people that basically
would collude and talk without me were
in groups saying okay this is what the
tour is going to be this is his next
house and they were making all these
decisions and they're making all this
money and at the end I was like I ended
my tour and I don't have the money and
it just so happens that that's the case
that what they were but what I'm saying
is if everyone can say
hey you can't point out this fact or
we're gonna say you're anti-semitic and
we're going to call you Hitler I feel
that there has to be at least one
percent of safeguarding the ability to
screw the artist based on saying it's
anti-semitic by pointing out that they
just so happened to all be uh Jewish
and I don't think that's anti-Semitism I
just think that's hey this is another
thing like okay the Kardashians when you
hear that do you think male or do you
think female
you think female you're gonna say you
think this is the realities this is why
rap works right they're gonna make an
anti-women thing in a second right and
it's gonna say well if you point out
that these five women six women are
having a meeting on where the Christmas
party is and none of the ball players
are rappers that they have babies with
have any say so so that Christmas
happened at Courtney's house all eight
years when I was there and it never
happened at anyone else's black family
house right
if I'm the one that pointed it out they
just don't have they they don't have
their oh you're anti-semitic word to say
shut the [ __ ] up yeah but because this
is the way it runs and this is the way
we want to do it if you say that though
that women are silencing the black voice
yes you're gonna get the same response
but especially if historically it's not
the fact that it's true
when you talk in groups
that breathes hate
when you talk about individuals it
solves problems if you're an engineering
okay but this is something I pointed out
on Pierce I said if a black person gets
pulled over with a car and it's three
other people in the car they're also
going to jail they're not going to
single them out they're going to say you
guys are all in collusion I just
describe collusion five times in this
interview
and you keep on going back to this is
like 1930. this is like this this is
like that what I'm saying is look I want
to work with you as an engineer to free
my people can we start as a being with
engineer opportunities right here I I am
sorry to the people who had to be hurt
and affected by that now we are here and
I'm looking to solve it but what happens
is every time if I talk to any of these
business people one by one because mind
you I didn't get to the Tweet by not
having a conversation I had the
conversations beforehand before I got to
the Tweet now we gonna take it to the
stage now we're on the world stage right
and you saw Ari Emmanuel do exactly the
kind of thing that I was saying have
been done behind closed doors now he's
doing it and open doors they told
Candace Owens I couldn't be on the daily
wire like you can't even explain
yourself
and we don't care have how you got to
that point either and that's [ __ ] up
they told Kansas you can't be understood
yeah yeah she did that's what they said
and you know what and you can have my
voice raised or lower I'm gonna do it
lower right because what's happening to
me by I put in your words the media is
saying
not only
can you not explain yourself we don't
care how you got to that point you need
to apologize and you can't explain and
that's the end of the story so just
apologize so we can have Mel Gibson do
some more films
is exactly what Ari Emmanuel was saying
no one is looking to change the problem
that led so many people to that same
level of frustration and I just so
happen to be the one that's not going to
back up on it until this changes because
you know what I'm sorry I had a sleepy
text I'm sorry I would I'm sorry for
everything I'm sorry that I I put uh
that I was uh 5 12 or 511 on uh Tinder
okay my [ __ ] is not 14 inches I lied
okay it's only 13. yeah so I'm sorry
right so the
oh he's dropping so many facts today so
what I'm saying is but where do we get
to this because even you
as engineering as intelligent as you are
you just like everyone else that I was
saying was colluding won't let us get to
the point of fixing it yeah but I'm not
I think you're more powerful than the
media I'm not saying you need to
apologize because the media I'm saying
everything we've been talking about just
because I care for you and I want you to
be the best possible man you can be to
me a definition of a great man I'm with
Martin Luther King on this you don't
talk about Jews or or black people you
talk about engineering you talk about
Humanity you solve problems you identify
the problems in the world and you don't
come from a place of resentment this
group did this this [ __ ] all that
um that is in the past you just build
Solutions I'm going to create a new
record label I'm going to create a new
design firm I'm going to create a new
Social Network I'm going to do better
I'm gonna do it right I'm gonna do it
right by the people that I know don't
have a voice I'm gonna give them a voice
and talk about that is it okay to call
out collusion do people collude in your
business under you like like the
engineers that come together and like
say they collude against the bosses
right you know why Bernardino offered
the deal and took it away from me
collusion
because I was too powerful but the
collective that I had right there he had
to stop that at all costs they said for
whatever reason this kid yay it has the
ability to have all of the Kardashians
Jay-Z and Beyonce uh Justin Bieber dimna
Virgil due to all these people in the
same room working towards the same goal
I've been that person
since preschool that's called a leader
right and right now what I'm saying is
hey
for the people in business whatever
their background is whether they turn
their whether they turn their cell
phones off on Friday or not
there's been some bad business done
there's some bad business practices and
we have to change that because
this game is like boxing more people end
up [ __ ] than rich
and I'm saying like beat to a pope
Driven Crazy beat by the media to a pope
right now the media has done everything
they could to make me apologize and to
make me look crazy and that one person
has done anything to find out why I was
frustrated enough to do that tweet and
that's facts and that's [ __ ] up
well I I was hoping to I am finding out
we found out I mean but like I want
Solutions like see there's something
about human nature where if you focus
too much on resentment we're not
focusing on anymore [ __ ] the results man
we're moving forward right so there's
two things I think that are required for
I mean this is how I've lived my life
for great engineering you surround
yourself in your personal life
by people you trust
and then in your professional life from
the engineering perspective with the
team
with an incredible team and everything
else doesn't matter that allows you not
to focus on other groups how they're
[ __ ] you over how they're like trying
to manipulate or collude and all that
kind of stuff you focus on Solutions and
you find a way around all the difficult
[ __ ]
that's it if you have people in your
life you can trust
that's like lifelong you said like some
people at your wood for the summer
for a year find people you can be with
for your whole life do you have people
in your life that you trust like really
trust
no I trust God
at any point a human being can like I
could like if I like go and like
really
you know treat this guy like a piece of
[ __ ] or do this am I supposed to you
know trust him to be loyal and stay in
the situation or I trust people to be
people and people are flawed and people
can have the right intentions but only
makes sense for us to work together when
our agendas align
when Kim was pulled really far to to the
to the left our agenda is no longer you
know aligned so that made the marriage
impossible it in a line where it's like
oh I could wear a red hat that can help
her to get Alice Johnson out of jail
because Trump's willing to do that for
my wife because I was the only person in
my position that stood up and said wait
a second I like you you know because but
isn't there a deeper agenda the human
agenda of just being in love like that's
just Paul were you talking about red hat
is just politics right I mean the world
is becoming more and more transactional
every day and actually marriages are
actually uh actually originally based on
transactions you know and that's why
they're less needed the more autonomous
as we come or the world makes it less
needed I feel like we do need each other
I feel like we do need someone we can
always
you know count on it's like I'm yay
pulled away by King Koopa which is the
media the politics the promise oh we're
going to keep you safe so the thing the
reason why I get you know really
frustrated with Kris Jenner is she says
losing Rob Kardashian was the greatest
mistake of her life but she never gave
Kim's hand over in marriage because this
is the bottom line
when men came back we were millionaires
or whatever right you're telling me you
just hand her hand over a marriage that
your daughter's not successful handing
your hand over in marriage too but no
she had to still be the husband to all
of her daughters and
we see what the results are consistently
so that's where I get you know
frustrated it's like let that go let
this person
do what you made mistakes on don't make
this person relive those same mistakes
and then put that agenda into my
daughters too
is there somebody in your life close to
you that that you trust enough to call
you out on your [ __ ] we're all full
of [ __ ] sometimes
what's my [ __ ]
well some of it I pointed out today but
I don't know you deeply enough what was
the book Jewish media Jewish that's not
[ __ ]
the [ __ ] is that the Jewish men
won't admit your dad was right your dad
was right the words you used the you
weren't the point you said it you're not
gonna make me say it 800 more times
I don't know if it resonated because you
keep saying like the words did it
resonate to y'all that y'all and do
nothing about it and that all y'all want
to do is have somebody apologize and
sweep under the rug your [ __ ] that
you've been doing the whole time you on
the same [ __ ] as the other people
so you're doing the same thing that the
other let's say media because I'm not
allowed to say has done so until
somebody which is what man it's just
what is I'm trying to call you out in
your [ __ ] because I hope I'm
somebody you can trust I don't [ __ ]
trust you
well you should find people in your life
you can trust don't tell me what I
should do I'm not one of your BLM
Marchers listen I'm with you on the BLM
a lot of organizations use tragedy it
and
um and I watched the Candace Owens
documentary
and what was your take on it
I think it's important to question the
mainstream narratives but I don't agree
with it I still believe that George
Floyd
died
from the knee of the cop
not from Fentanyl and and even if that
was the case there's still 50 percent of
black deaths is actually abortion
so let's get into engineering let's just
go because that's how do you fix that
population control of social engineering
and and it's most literal form
the blacks that are under population
control
that's something that I mean that's just
what it is African-Americans are not
choosing to get the abortion I mean it's
a choice it's an individual choice but
we're being influenced too
well then speak to the community and
help I mean I don't know what the
engineering Solutions there are
it could be I you're doing that in part
by speaking to the value and the power
of family well well watch this I was
building
shelters I bought
land in Calabasas I bought two ranches
in Wyoming 300 acres in Calabasas 12 000
acres in total in Wyoming and I started
building ideas for shelters
and God said it on my heart to make
monasteries which would be modern day
facility facilities that don't turn
people down that have Farms
that have
shelter clothing but first of all water
first of all knowledge because knowledge
is the most important resource to our
species above water knowledge it's
itself because then you can go get water
I mean you could argue like if you're a
baby had equal but
but the baby doesn't have it you know so
someone with the knowledge then feeds
the
uh baby the water but it's important
that those with the knowledge teach the
baby how to find the water themselves
and
the business people that I've been
dealing with have been keeping the baby
sick
by not sharing the information and the
knowledge with inside of those contracts
my people are sick if I load up
Apple music right now
and I play the top songs in the rap
chart I would tell you my people are
sick if I go to the restaurants in
Opportunity zones and we look at the
calorie rating and the cholesterol I
will tell you that my people are sick if
we look at the obesity rate if you go to
just uh a restaurant somewhere in Middle
America Denny's or something I went to
denny's the other day you will see that
my people are sick and my people meaning
all people right but black people are
very influential to all people so right
if so if the media picks uh overweight
black woman and says this is body goals
then the media are influencing my people
to stay sick and it just so happens that
that night
I was so frustrated after 20 years
that I had to call it out in one tweet
that now
even if I say hey okay I was frustrated
for these reasons now it's not good
enough you've literally tried to make me
reapologize 10 times in this meeting
re-say this re-say that but it doesn't
change the fact that my people are sick
and I'm the only person in my position
that will say that my people are sick
today not 30 years ago not 60 years my
people are sick today 50 of my peoples
of deaths are abortion today my people
don't have the opportunities today
even to the point that because if JP
Morgan have been nice to me and if Alice
Klein and stem player had been fair to
me different things then I wouldn't even
point it out that we don't have any
black we have two black Engineers so I
have to have a responsibility obviously
to all people but specifically to My
Tribe because tribes
tribes move you know tribalism is real
with black people to separate the
brightest from the tribe or to separate
the leaders it is factual that the CIA
removed the leaders from the black
community put crack in the communities
put guns in the communities and locked
up all the leaders and called them
gangly right locked up all the leaders
locked up all the fathers now 72 percent
of black mothers are raising
children by themselves this is a gender
like a Tuskegee experiment set on my
people right and what I'm calling out
for the black people in entertainment is
what are we doing we have to collude and
if we don't collude because even if I
said hey I'd like to make a company
that's all black
right is that okay for me to say
is that okay for me to say or is that
anti-Semitic
see if I hadn't crossed the line so far
then that would have sounded
anti-Semitic now I've stretched a bit so
now we can go to okay let's make an
all-black company but that would have
been anti-Semitic
just that concept because you could word
that in a different way that would sound
anti-Semitic
I don't know man I have to no no listen
what if you were if I said I didn't want
to have the Jewish people in the company
would that be anti-Semitic
it would sound like it right you'd say
I'm from 1930s right yeah but for me as
a tribe to say no I want an all-black
company right I'm generally against that
kind of thing but you first of all you
have the right to do whatever the hell
you want well what I'm saying is that's
what I feel may need to happen for my
people to have power again because when
my people have been left under the
media's control we've been made sick
we've been allowed to be sick we've been
promo and we're promoting sickness I
think at least in the engineering realm
I haven't met an engineer
who happens to be black who would like
to be called a black engineer and when
you have a company of all black people
that are Engineers I don't know the
creative arts I apologize but
engineering
the really tried to look at each other
as humans and look at the problem and
you want to know you want to have the
confidence that everybody on the team is
the best possible person for the job
what I can say is
the world is sick
and
I have slight images
of Utopia slight images of Happiness
slight images as a Visionary and a
creator
and I know for a fact the way that
business deals have been done for me
are keeping the world sick
fix them
I see that's what you're trying to do
and you probably listen people should
not doubt yay but I gotta tell you I
have to be honest
um I don't this is silly because you
don't know me but it hurt when you say
you don't trust me you kind of lost me
I don't think anyone's ever said that to
me
I don't know man
[ __ ] that you're I'm not I don't care
about
uh views or clickbait or any of that
[ __ ]
um I just thought you're one of the
great greatest artists ever it'd be cool
to talk to you and I just I feel like
you got pain you're working through and
never had anyone say that to me I I
maybe I'm just being a mess about it I
guess that's [ __ ] up though but maybe
it's not maybe you shouldn't trust it
but I just haven't had that experience I
yeah do you think I would trust
anybody at this point in my life yeah
it's tough
it's tough it's tough I hear you and uh
I it's it's also kind of good to see how
much strength you got you're not broken
by any of this you're under a lot of
attack
a lot of attack
by a lot of people
you have a vision and you're trying to
feel your way through it and you might
get destroyed for it
that's the human uh that's the risk you
take
It's a Wonderful Life though
what do you hope your legacy is
to be forgotten
do you think you'd be forgotten
because the memory there's ego and
memory and the memories
who designed the sidewalk who designed
the water fountain who designed the stop
sign who designed the stoplight these
things are so ubiquitous that the person
that designed them is forgotten
if it's a good idea it's a god idea
and I don't know VCS can own it
so you want your designs in all Realms
of life to be so simple
that they
they permeate everything they take over
and you are forgotten that's a
successful design is you're forgotten
yes
you have advice for people a lot a lot a
lot of young people look up to you give
advice for young people
I've had to live a life they can be
proud of
don't tweet while you're sleepy
take a nap
surely there's other things I love the
humor don't take it seriously I suppose
is what that means
we don't don't send sleepy tweets uh
unless you buy your own social platform
the very next week call parlor but other
than that if you're not gonna buy your
own social plan then is that why you
bought parlors so you could be sleepy
and send messages out into the wild
I actually am really interested in the
engineering aspects of parlor is there a
vision there because I'm also super
interested in Elon buying Twitter I like
Instagram
uh better than Twitter and I'm sure Mark
Zuckerberg liked Instagram better than
Facebook or saw how
uh you know how valuable that was and he
bought it so you'd like to take Apollo
or something whatever is the magic that
makes Instagram work you want to push
you well I thought it was interesting
how it felt like Snapchat made the
Kardashians bully Instagram what what's
the what's the point of Snapchat going
to war
one on Instagram
yeah I mean just everyone wants to say
well this is our value Snapchat you know
no one wants to lose their value to
someone else's value whatever it's like
and everything is just what's the
difference between permanent and
temporary
you know it's just a permanent structure
and until God says it's not you know
it's like nothing's permanent our life
is not permanent
so how do we just let go those things
even like going from the name Kanye West
to yay was the beginning of just letting
go
of some things of these titles like we
need to remove the titles like hey if I
if I have to leave Adidas and I have to
go next computers
that may take me out of the billionaire
standing all together
and I Gotta Get Low for however long God
says I have to get low and refocus I've
been
re-shaping refocusing my staff
I had some people that were good and I
had some people that weren't I had too
many people and I've got a vision inside
of me and I'm like this is how I make
this Vision I have to bring this Vision
to life
I have to bring these houses to life I
was talking to
um one of our architects
on
you know we're actually getting close on
it I've like built it a few times I had
like the domes you probably saw and kind
of and I said you know how he
transformed Kim's house and
you know we're getting there like so you
want to get into architecture like you
really you really want to become
physical reality yes and I've got close
Rome wasn't built to today yeah but Rome
had to start somewhere yeah I gotta call
you out on the advice there really is a
lot of people that look up to you and
you've lived a really difficult life
and you made it through all of it
what what what do you advise them to do
do everything that you feel
even if you are told that it's the wrong
thing no no no no no but not anything
violent
should do what you feel say what you
feel like trust your heart yeah trust
your gut trust your instincts because
that instinct is who God made you to be
not you know what lines up with your
life frat brothers or what lines up with
what your dad wanted or what lines up
with your classmates or you know it's
just
God has something inside of you and when
you walk down the street you're thinking
about it and then you just see it in the
window
and you go down another stream you see
the same thing or you're thinking about
a number and that number pops up or you
see it on a license plate and that's
just
you know
something is trying to say be the
maximum
yay you know be the maximum you and God
will give you anything that you can't
handle so for me
everything is a yes I think they say Be
Like Water I know Bruce Lee said that
or matter of fact just be
because we are beings with engineering
opportunities
beautifully put yay uh I have hope I
have faith that
however this turns out that
you have the skill and the capacity to
really add love to the world and I hope
you do that
I really really hope you do that and we
talked about the tension of that the
challenges and the opportunities of that
I mean I see
how we could be of use to each other you
actually have a particular thing for me
as I eject from media because even also
you know I'm really big at like you know
burning the Phoenix too all you know as
an engineer that yourself completely
regenerate every seven years I think I I
rushed the process a little bit so I run
around looking like a burn victim
sometimes yeah but I gotta tell you
anyone I I'm close with I work with
there has to be trust there has to be
love and I think you've been burned
quite a bit in your life
sometimes I did it myself I put my hand
on the stove
so how do we get to engineering there's
a deal to be done here not saying you're
making this money off of that I'm making
that money off but there's I don't care
about money by the way same twins so
there's dealings here
you got pain I got pain but we're beings
with engineering opportunities for a
long time I thought somebody should
create a new Social Network
and it looks like
great engineering can do that you got
two at one time from two of your
homeboys at one time yeah and that's a
great way I mean every you know it can
be done from scratch or it can be done
Anew with an already established
platform yeah now I'm very excited by
that possibility
uh parlor smaller Twitter is larger I
wonder whether you can do any kind of
revolutionary engineering with a large
company if anyone can I would say it's
Elon well Elon can look at what we do
over here that's why I like God does
this a lot of times uh he creates uh
doppelgangers there's a lot of examples
where Theory happened two places at one
time a really similar type of
Personality happens at one time it's
weird it's beautiful it's hilarious
actually yeah it's kind of humorous
so we should we should just share
every piece of information together as
like as I go bill
parlor and as he builds up Twitter and
see how to make both those better but
I'll I'll be like hey I'm not gonna let
Snapchat bully me out of
you know adding something to it that's
best it should just be the best platform
possible that means that you know that
means Tick Tock has
amazing features Twitter has amazing
things about it I know this girl that's
like I like Instagram better than
Twitter it's just she likes that Twitter
has porn
but other than that Instagram but I was
like well Instagram is porn also it's
like soft it's more subtle it's not
telling you it's not it's not
conservative
by any means
you know and I mean that's the thing you
have to please a lot of people with
these platforms and I think the goal of
a platform should be to um help
individuals
maximize their long-term happiness and
growth like intellectually
spiritually psychologically all that
it's a tricky thing to figure out how to
do that
of course you could just have a platform
that's just strictly for fun I think
that's where Tick Tock leans
but
um there has I think there's a balance
to strike like Twitter there's a lot of
intellectual philosophical stuff going
on on Twitter but it somehow currently
makes it too easy to be divisive and
hateful towards each other and cancel
and all that kind of stuff I think we
need to have these healthy conversations
that's what it is healthy conversations
healthy dialogues that's the biggest
thing like
when I first wore the red hat
the conversation is less healthy than it
is today
the conversation about George Floyd
you know it's like did I send the Tweet
the right way did is Candace Owens
documentary perfect is a what Michael
Moore as that documentary is perfect a
Sentry self is it fully accurate you
know it's
two to three hours of a trans minute of
information through a particularly
usually one person's View
and anything you want to research if
you're interested in it
you gotta look at 10 versions of it 20
versions of it George Floyd we've looked
at one version of that now we have a
second whoa
by the time we get to the
you know I know this is like
it's it's not my last hoodie
but it's definitely not my first hoodie
that I put on you know it's like that's
how we got to like even this particular
size of zipper or the fact that you know
for people who know they know that
that's like Carhartt
even though the Carhartt tag isn't there
anymore you just know by the shape of it
you feel it so it it abstracts it takes
into like this Cubist place like Picasso
Matisse or African cubism or uh Dire
Straits Money for Nothing and your
chicks for free
I wouldn't think you could reference uh
Dire Straits look at you that video yeah
I know it's a great video that video
your encyclopedic knowledge of music is
great I think that
you know porn is not just sexual that
term actually relates to torture like
yeah I'm saying like watching people
beat each other up on on Worldstar or
something you know it's like that's
called torture porn there's also food
porn
how do you explain that what's foodborne
food porn is like looking at really
delicious cakes and cookies and steak
and so on and you're like holy [ __ ]
exactly architecture like this people
who love architecture when they see
architecture I know I got friends
they'll be like oh that's porn yeah
architecture yeah yeah it's like uh
that's like love like dopamine fueled
love for a thing
yeah we need that's beautiful I think
that's beautiful well I think as long as
nobody's getting hurt the intoxication
that people have
you know the worst part is like when one
person's in love and the other persons
didn't like
that's us right now
who's unlike no cause you said you love
Bill Maher and you like me
and I love you so that was no I actually
love you both all right all right and
the funny thing is like um
as a
as a Visionary Visionaries are
more extreme
than business people
because a Visionary would do bad
business for their vision
a business person will never do bad
business so I'll put yeah through the
output So when you say I don't care
about money it's like yeah I feel you
like I feel that I care in a way that I
need that but
I care about the vision that I have to a
Steve Jobs level
to the point of
putting that above
my regular human existence meaning
having to go and take all the arrows
that I become a soldier of division
because someone could say a wife could
say to like say like in the 60s
their husbands about to go to war
the the wife may not want their husband
to go to war
because of their children
but he's going to war
because of their children
definitely do you regret any aspect of
just giving everything to your vision
I mean you've spoken about that saying
like I got [ __ ] over in the business
side I promise that I had to stop
envying
cool people
at their current cool time
if anything
if someone's cool
and I say their name a lot I'm gonna
Flash
the light on them so much that it ages
their coolness it's actually a war
technique
showered in compliments yeah yeah
because that that you that to be able to
stay at 45 years old to still be the bad
kid in class at 45 I'm still in the
principal's office because if you look
at like say fashion right if you think
of something fashionable it's probably
gonna look like the kid in the
principal's office
that's going to be the fashion and
that's part of the reason why I'm the
most influential person and fashion and
fashion because I refuse to leave the
principal's office if the substitute
teacher comes in I'm gonna say you got a
big butt yeah I'm gonna get and they go
right back right back to the principal's
office and people gonna be like yo
and that's what you keep on saying like
who can we talk to
because no one can talk to me no I'm out
of control bro it's just God then me and
then [ __ ] everybody you know I mean
that's how that's really how I live my
life
and I would just want to say this one
thing about the children thing I wanted
to you know put that point together put
that idea together that I don't like the
word point I'm really big on like Words
Words being powerful says the person
with the Sleepy tweet
um so you're full of contradictions yeah
I'm a human being right it's like some
days I'm like I could go 30 days to be
celibate you know like really like I'm a
monk I'm being like faithful to God and
then I'll go like working out no carbs
like my weight will fluctuate and I'll
have time so I'm like I don't feel like
being told what to do so I don't want to
work out with a trainer and I just want
to drink this Hennessy but I want to say
this thing that I will text to Kim
sometimes I'll say you know
you may not understand
what I'm doing right now but you will
and that's what I would say to everyone
you may not understand what I'm doing
and this gives a little bit maybe we're
like 20 there but there's still going to
be people we leave this interview and
they'll be like I still don't like the
way you apologize I still don't want to
say what my involvement would have been
to make him lead him to that point and
we just want things to be how they are
there's people in the world who want the
world to stay as it is and there's
people who want to change the world and
that's happened throughout time they say
that with da Vinci halfway into a
conversation he could not suffer fools
so much that he would walk away halfway
into the conversation and I said well
that's why
it's The DaVinci Code and at The DaVinci
world
and every time I go and piss off a group
of people or do these things on some end
it's like I could be turning my thing
from a potential World Vision to a code
or I could be opening up conversations
with new friends that I may trust
someday yeah that's beautiful that's
beautiful that that because the change
you will have on the world that you
don't know for sure but it'll happen
across
uh years even decades so you have to
think in the future like you're working
in the future your actions are working
in the future and a lot of people will
judge this conversation and others
you've done and so on in the present and
that doesn't matter you know why I
apologize when I say I'm sorry to the
Jewish people that I hurt
it's not about like I said oh I said I'm
not gonna hold this apology hostage
right it's obviously it's about God but
God is everything right so what's the
point of having language and being you
can't engineer if he's a God God right
it's like it's God has us to be
judgmental so that you become if you're
a doctor right it's your judgment that
saves grandma right and God puts that in
this like we have God inside us we're a
peace of God also right so I'm gonna go
specific to a person
that story about DaVinci alone
is enough of a reason for me to give a
sincere apology to the Jewish people
because I do believe that there's a da
Vinci Code inside of all of my
misspellings and scribbles right here
that God wants me to get to the world
and
when I'm in my way if God has set
something on me when I'm in my way I'm
in God's way now I can point at other
people and say hey you guys are in God's
way because you're not listening to me
but if I'm in my way I'm not listening
to God and for me to be a philosopher
and a leader whatever other language I
have to listen to God so before God what
I will do is start off as a samurai
and say I'm sorry for hurting you
as a Jewish person I'm sorry for the way
that made you feel and I'm sorry for the
entire
uh population of a race that I feel is
actually my brothers because I classify
and feel that I'm also connected with
Christ in that way that my people came
from Africa and that way and I can't say
it's this exact teaching or that exact
teaching but I feel that there's an
important you know the sons of Abraham
however we want to word it right for us
to come together and bring our different
talents together to serve God
collectively And he as much of an alien
as I am he does not cause me he did not
call for me to alienate and that's what
the problem has been especially in
politics and in America he plays America
as the TV as the radio to the World We
Invented rock and roll right we are the
influencers of the rest of the planet
we're the um we're the youngest startup
in history right we're the youngest
country where the we're the youngest
superpower right so for me in my
position the fact that I can talk to
Trump one day and be at a game with Kim
Kardashian the next day and then be at
Paris fashion week they don't want me to
be involved with language of decisive
divisive language you know proving that
I can be just as racist as a racist
white person oh I can I could be a
racist black person also that's not what
God has called me to do so how do I
simplify and say hey to you as a
Visionary as a as an engineer as a
person that's given me a platform that
as my brother I want to apologize to you
for how that made you feel and to the
rest of
the people that carry specifically that
pain not the pain that I talk about that
doesn't seem to be as much of a pain for
people when I talk about the abortion
clinics and stuff that's it's like
that's the argued pain even in my own
Community like not everyone thinks it's
a pain but for the Jewish Community it's
collectively this was a pain and I've
gone I've gone so far just
psychologically on this journey since
that statement had happened
where I didn't want to like give up the
candy in my pocket I didn't want to say
hey I stuck my can my hand in the candy
jar I wanted to defend my freedom of
speech I wanted this but even with
freedom of speech pain is pain causing
people to hurt is not helping causing
people to hurt is not helping so that
means I have to take a a more
sophisticated approach
to
engineering this problem this problem is
the opportunity
and yes
that what could some people may deem as
a mistake would it be more genuine if I
called it a mistake
I think I would be uh hypocritical by
calling a mistake with what the end of
that the idea I'm gonna say out loud so
I I'm not I don't try to be a hypocrite
on purpose uh so but I will call it a
mistake to add a genuine uh to be
genuine
about the feeling
with that mistake
with me as a human being
not to justify but I have to state that
God makes no mistakes because if I
hadn't made that mistake I wouldn't be
in front of you today and that's not to
justify
this
uh
uh sleepy text but I can tell you're a
man that has love in his heart and I
hear that I hear it through the words
explicitly and implicitly and I I think
if we're to engineer a better future the
way to do that is with love
so as one human to another I love you
brother thank you for talking today this
is great
I like you too son of a [ __ ]
thanks for listening to this
conversation with yay formerly known as
Kanye West to support the spot guest
please check out our sponsors in the
description and now let me leave you
with some words from yay himself
Nothing in life is promised
accept death
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time